من قال ذلك، إنه قول مروع ولكن مبدأ "
العين بالعين" يجعل الجميع
أعمى الآن، بعد أن أصبحوا رقبة الغابة،
يؤمنون حقًا بفكرة العين بالعين
بأكملها، ولكنني أعتقد أنك تمتلكها حقًا
إذا كنت لن تفعل ذلك فقط
ارتكاب إبادة جماعية بشكل صريح كما هو الحال ضد
شعب بأكمله والذي من الواضح أنه لن
يكون مقبولاً ولا ينبغي أن يكون
مقبولاً لأي شخص، فأنت
ستترك أساسًا الكثير من الأشخاص
على قيد الحياة الذين تعرفهم بعد ذلك إسرائيل،
لذا فالسؤال حقًا هو مثل  فكيف
لكل عضو في حماس تقتله كم
خلقت همم وإذا
خلقت أكثر مما تقتل فأنت لم
تنجح هذا هو ما تعرفه عن
الوضع الحقيقي هناك أم ومن الآمن أن تقول
ذلك إذا كنت تعرف أم
إذا كنت تعرف  إذا قتلت طفل شخص ما
في
غزة، فقد خلقت على الأقل عددًا قليلًا من
أعضاء حماس الذين سيموتون لمجرد
قتل
إسرائيلي، هذا هو الوضع،
لكني أعني أن هذا أحد
أكثر المواضيع إثارة للجدل التي يمكن
للمرء أن يناقشها ولكن  لكنني أعتقد أنه إذا
كان الهدف النهائي هو نوع من
السلام طويل الأمد، فيجب على المرء أن ينظر إلى
هذا من وجهة نظر بمرور الوقت، فهل
هناك عدد أكبر أو أقل من الإرهابيين الذين يتم
خلقهم